pourquoi at on envie d'uriner quand il
fait froid c'est vrai que c'est pas
pratique les spécialistes ne savent pas
vraiment d'où vient ce besoin selon
certains le froid stimule l'apport de
sang vers les muscles ce qui entraîne
leur contraction or la vessie est un
muscle et quand elle se contracte elle
pousse plus rien' vers la sortie pour
d'autres ce serait une histoire de nerfs
stimulée par le froid et qui via le
cerveau entraînerait une envie d'uriner
selon une autre théorie enfin le froid
obligerait les reins à extraire plus
dodue sans que d'habitude et donc à
produire plus du rin le résultat est
cependant toujours le même quelle que
soit l'explication il faut vite trouver
des toilettes